>> Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen. I'm
Mike Aizatsky, I'm working at the App Engine
team and today we're going to talk about Batch
Data Processing with Google App Engine. So
during the session live notes will be available
in Google Wave and you can also pass your
questions. So please write down this obscure
URL which is ds6t9F. So a little bit about
agenda; so first of all, we're going to spend
a little time talking about batch processing.
What is it? How is it different from what
Brett was talking about? Then just to give
you a little introduction to the topic, I
will talk about how was data processing done
in App Engine up-to-date, then I will tell
you how we do batch processing at Google,
then we're going to spend the rest of the
session about how we would like you to do
your batch processing from, starting from
today. So, batch data processing is the task
of off-line processing of lots and lots of
data, lots of entities, thousands of entities,
a common use cases of schema migration, export
in and input in data, report generation of
whatever. And the core difference is with
what Brett was talking about this is not real
time tasks. So this is something that you
just sprung, take a cup of tea or go to sleep
and it finishes in the morning depending on
how much data you've got. And for some, for
certain reasons this is a difficult stuff
in App Engine. First of all, they're all like
certain restrictions in App Engine, which
are not created because we like those, because
we need those restrictions because we need
automatic scalability, we need replication,
reliability, and that's why we have got a
30-second request limit, which are really
hard to try, which we're really trying to
overcome. Sometimes there are transient errors
in the system which happens in all distributed
systems. We have non-zero latency for Datastore.
We've got occasional, pretty rare but still
occasional timeouts. And what's really important,
everyone got changing datasets. So you want
a batch processor where you're changing data
which complicates this stuff a little bit.
So when App Engine was launched, the only
way to do data, batch data processing was
to define a batch handler. Do something which
you'd be able to fit into 30 seconds and start
another process we feel be in your page continuously.
It might be just a curl, it might be a browser.
And actually, Alan is sitting here, Alan did
the first thing at the very first day when
App Engine was launched. Do you remember there
were invitations? So we had to process them
somehow. So we created a browser page which
was doing refresh and sending out all those
invitations. There are some problems with
the [INDISTINCT]. First of all, we need some
external driver which might fail and like
a computer which you got to have to keep your
laptop on, you have to keep it, plug it in
to the network, if network fails and your
process stops. There are also difficulties
of who is doing all the error handling, recoveries
when errors happen and the whole process is
slow. I mean, what's the top QPS you can drive
from a single computer? Maybe 50, if you're
lucky enough but I doubt that. And the whole
state management of the process is really,
really complex. People created lots of improvements
over the two years when App Engine is--well,
over two years. They've got--you can communicate
with the driver or you can use remote APIs
for really complex scenarios, or even have
got a Bulkloader too which does exactly that.
This is something which is running in your
computer and which drives the traffic to your
web app to perform some batch computations.
A year ago, we have launched a really, really
nice system which we like a lot and we used
throughout all apps and this is called the
Task Queue. Task Queue can perform any kind
of work outside of a user driven request.
You just in-queue it, it will be done later.
And it's really reliable, high performance,
high throughput system, but it still got a
30-second limit. So people have created a
task chaining technique, this is something
which you use to overcome the 30-second limit.
Basically, it run for some time and as soon
as you see that your time is ending, when
you're close to 25 seconds, you can queue
another task and finish your job. So you--effectively,
it splits your job in batches and each batch
is processed by a separate task; and the code
looks kind of okay. So you define the same
kind of app handler, you get the next batch
from somewhere, a common place to put starting
point is in the request headers then you do
some work, define where to continue working
then you queue the continuations. And it's
really easy to start. The whole process of
adjusting queue the first task and it will
continue to go through your Datastore. And
people have been successfully using it and
there are lots of libraries for doing that
kind of stuff. And Task Queue is really, really
nice for doing that kind of work. First of
all, it guarantees sequential task execution.
No matter what happens, be it timeouts, problems,
schedule of maintenance, unscheduled maintenance,
whatever happens, Task Queue guarantees that
your task will be executed. You do not need
any kind of external drivers. You can fire
your task and go home, close your computer,
leave and sleep well. Task Queue repeats task
execution if something bad has happened. If
you have some kind of unavailability or you
have some transcend error or your URL page
did not work through, you just return a 500
result code and Task Queue will retry and
it will back off if you have too many errors.
And also most people do not think about that,
but Task Queue can limit execution rate so
that you have a predictable resource consuming--consuming
predictable of resource, amount of resources
because it's really easy for Task Queue to
blow up through the whole budget in one hour.
It would just execute a couple million of
tasks and just spend all your money for today.
So the whole App Engine idea is to take something
which works for Google and to give it to external
developers. And it's true that every single
App Engine runs in the same servers, in the
same datacenters which our usual day-to-day
problems run. We don't have any special datacenters
for you. We don't have any special infrastructure
built. At Google, MapReduce is being used
for years and years to do batch processing
our Google scale. And MapReduce is a system
that was specifically created to help developers
work with unreliable distributed systems,
storages, fail-overs, retries and it's really,
really widely adopted. So at Google, there
are thousands and thousands of MapReduce jobs
running. MapReduce is really, really a simple
thing. It just defines only two functions.
Functions to define the map functions which
take your data chunk maybe entity and it produces
at least pairs of key values. Then there is
a hidden magic step which is called shuffle,
which groups all values with the same keys
together. And then there is a reduce function
which is also supplied by developer, which
takes key and also shaded values. And it's
amazing that how broad tasks can be completed
with the Task Queue. A special interest of
schema migration task, which is usually an
empty reduce. So you've got only map functions
which will reliably scans through your old
dataset and in your update function and in
your map function you just update your Datastore
and migrate or compute something. And another
one, a really a special case, is report generation.
When a step of reduce function you just generate,
you report entities, which have some report
data for consuming with other pages of other
apps or other tools. We would really like
to give you the same MapReduce which we are
using at Google internally. We would really
like for you to use the same implementation,
the same systems, but unfortunately, there
are bigger and there are some unique challenges
which we have at App Engine. First of all,
we've got additional scaling dimension which
is not common for Google. We've got lots of
applications which were written by you guys.
There are thousands and thousands of apps
and we expect that many of them will run MapReduce
at the same time. And this scaling dimension
was not anticipated by our MapReduce engineering
team so MapReduce cannot do that. And another
problem is that we want to isolate all apps
so that if some app is behaving badly or consuming
lots of resources, then other apps should
not be hurt. So no one wants to have his MapReduce
is running slow because someone else is running
his MapReduce. So we want to do lots and lots
of isolation stuff. We also want to do rate
limiting, which is a surprising requirement
because at Google we want our MapReduces to
continue as fast as possible. But we realize
that that is not what you guys want because
we can consume thousand dollars of resources
per hour and not everyone might be happy with
the rate of resource spending. So you'd probably
want to limit your resource consumption and
some apps even want a very, very slow execution.
If you're a free app, you've got a certain
amount of quota daily, you do not want to
consume it in five minutes and queue your
app or whatever. And the last but not the
least, people want a protection from malicious
App Engine users. There are some people who
tried to exploit our infrastructure to gain
some advantage or just take a look how Google
operates and we have to be protected from
that people. We have to protect your data
from those kinds of people. So, that means
that we could not take the existing MapReduce
and give it to you. So we have started to
build the whole system from scratch using
probably some building blocks which we have
already available. And we realized that we
already have a really, really nice subsystem
in App Engine which solves most of the problems
we're having and that system is called Task
Queue. So we decided to build our MapReduce
framework on top of Task Queue, probably editing
some necessary services while we go. So today,
I'm pleased to announce that we have successfully
completed part one of MapReduce story. We
have implemented map, which is not old MapReduce
but we decided that it's already useful enough
for you guys to work on. And it's reliable,
fast and efficient way to iterate over your
Datastore or blob files or whatever other
data sources possible. You can start playing
with it today and while we are extremely busy
of giving you the full MapReduce, you can
already start using it, take a look at our
APIs and write your code. First of all, the
code in Meta Library is completely user space.
You just pull those sources into your project
and it works. It's fully open source. So you
can tweak it, modify it, change to your needs,
see how it works. You can create patches,
send those back to us and we'll use them and
to use them to our code base. Today, we are
launching Python version. Unfortunately, Java
version was not in the state. We're happy
to open right now but it will come really,
really, really soon. And we try to make all
APIs very familiar to Hadoop and Dumbo users
so that it's close to be in source compatible.
But put it in reality, it means if you know
what Hadoop or Dumbo is, you can start really
fast. So speaking about features, we have
automatic sharding. So if you have a huge
dataset, we can process in parallel lots and
lots of shards. So we will split your datasets
into manageable chunks and works through them.
You can rate limit for slow execution. We
have status pages so that you can see how
well your MapReduce is doing. What is it doing?
What is the progress? We have counter support,
which means that you can count certain events
in your dataset and use it as a reporting
tool. We can have parameterized mappers so
that you can create a mapper which can be
used to its different parameters to tweak
or to tune what to work on. So that engineers
create MapReduce to an administrator, run
it later, or you can create re-useable MapReducers.
We have batching datastore operations so that
it works much, much faster than the code you
write by hand. And you can also iterate not
over the datastore only but over the blob.
So now we'll try to give you a small demo.
Let's hope that Wi-Fi gets--in good mood today.
So we created a small app which basically
scans the source code of the zip file which
we have uploaded and looks for certain irregular
expressions. So for this demo, we have uploaded
the source code of LinuxFi, or Linux code
of fi, which is approximately 100 megabytes
of a zip file which is close to one gigabyte
of your source code. So there is a MapReduce
system overview page which shows you all the
MapReduce which we have run recently. Here
they are, I'm going to zoom in. You can also
start a new job, so let's try it. These are
just parameters. This is not like really user
friendly, just some bare UI which we've got.
So, we specify the file ID. We began a look
for crap in Linux and the regular expression
will be crap and build it in 20 shards. So,
we're going hit run. It take sometime to analyze
the dataset and then queue all of the tasks.
So it says like, "Hey, the job was successfully
started. Here is a job which is being run."
We can check the Task Queue of our app. We
got 21 tasks, 59--we have already run at this
minute, that we will continue running. Meanwhile,
we can check the status page of individual
MapReduce which is, which will show us how
our MapReduce is doing. So, we can see it.
This is like a progress of each separate shard.
How many files has it processed? We can see
that by now, it had, it has done 4,000 map
recalls which is approximately 140 calls per
second which means they're processing 140
files per second. And you can see, if you're
interested in the status of individual shards,
how well are they doing, like how long does
it take, you can refresh and check. But meanwhile,
while it that gathers, it writes over data
to the Datastore so that we can already take
a look at the results. So this is all mention
of crap in the Linux source code. Depending
on the lack, like yesterday, same MapReduces
completed in two minutes. Today, it's took
like eight minutes which is, two minutes,
I think, is quiet good for one gig of source
files to do or gets on every line of every
source file in LinuxFi. So, we will probably
check later in the demo, in the presentation.
So we see that there are only nine shards
left so like 11 shards have already completed
in one minute 40 seconds in every single completed
eventually. So meanwhile, let's see how the
API looks like. Oops, I've lost those slides'
position. So, it is really--we try to make
it really, really easy for you to start using
the library. It takes exactly two steps. First
step, you checkout library from subversion
directly into your source code using the [INDISTINCT]
export and then you just add these three lines
to the [INDISTINCT]. You specify URL--so this
is an error, it sets at duplication. It should
say MapReduce and you say that this is admin
productive pages, which is probably a good
idea, you do not want your users to start
MapReduce. And it is really, really easy to
define any new mapper to do some work. You
define a simple function which takes only
one argument. You do some solicit argument
and you create a MapReduce yuml file in your
app, and just specify your map or how is it
go, it's operated over Datastore and it has
a handler that, those kind of stuff. And then
it can open your app and /MapReduce and all
the MapReduces will [INDISTINCT] you can start
those from the UI. In Java, it's going to
look a little bit more messy, like you have
to define class extend App Engine mapper key
entity. To be honest, I have left two additional
parameters, generic parameters here because
they come in from Hadoop, this is not our
interface, but this is exactly how Hadoop
interface looks like. So, you can write at
the same way, but it's quite simple anyway.
So, this is--first example, how you do your
Datastore operations? You specify a function.
You just accept, for example, user--you do
something with user. You tweak at properties,
you change its ages, we calculate something
and then you yield the operations you want
to be performed. You yield an operation to
be pulled from user and it’ll collect all
those operations together from multiple run
and we'll do them in batches. We make sure
that you do not cross a one megabyte of request
limit and all that kind of stuff. And this
boot you can also use delete or perhaps some
other kinds of operations. Counters can be
really--counters is just something which keeps
tracks of simple integer value and, you can
use it to build some kind of report generation.
For example, if you want to know how your
audience age distributed, it just introduce
lots of counters depending on the user age
and you increment a specific counter. And
on the status page, you would be able to seal
the counter fellows and you can have probably
the ability of migrating to a thousand counters.
So it's like we can do pretty nice reports
using counters alone without any difficulties.
And this is the example how you might generate
a more complex report. You, for example, if
you want to see how many goods each customer
has ordered for you, you define the mapper
over your customers then inside the code,
you will, all orders, for all orders by this
customer, you sum the total. You create the
report line and you yield an operation to
do the report line back. So, then you'll be
able to start this MapReduce. You can even
create a crone job which will run this mapper
like everyday and you will have a fresh report
every morning, there's all information you
need. Some implementation details is that
they’d be using Task Queue chaining to do
all the stuff and there are two types of flows
inside. The first one is a controller flow.
We have a separate task which oversees all
the execution, all the statuses, log messages,
whatever, and gathers information together,
helps to displays status page. And they have
working flow which you can have really a lot.
So, we've been running our examples, we explain
to you, you can have 4,800, it depends on
to the data rate you want to achieve. And
all this task use Datastore for storage and
communication. And we optimizes it, it's really
hard to do like just one read, one write,
doing the whole operation. So the overhead
is, there is some overhead of using this but
it’s pretty, pretty low. And we handle most
of the complexities. We're making sure that
there is no [INDISTINCT] written outs, there's
no infinite forking. But there is only one
thing which we would like you to keep thinking
about when you write MapReduce, is idempotence.
And idempotence is a really important concept
for all batch operation. So idempotence, in
mathematics, it means that if you apply a
function twice, so you can have the same result;
which in our case means that your batch handler
should be ready to process the same entity
twice because errors do happen and the way
we recover from errors would be rerun your
code in to the same entity. And sometimes
you might be unlucky that it would be rerun
twice. And this is the most important property
you should think about. You should--when you
write a batch operation, you should always
think, is it idempotent? Do I care about that
stuff? And let's take a look at some examples
of practical idempotent operation. So this
is naïve data migration which is not idempotent
because it creates a new property. It computes
it and it puts entity back, and if its run
twice, it might, on the same entity, it might
give not the same results which we'd like
to have. So--oops, the same code. I'm sorry
about that. So basically, the way to make
it idempotent is that, you have, it have to
checks it, you have performed a migration
to your entity already. If you have performed
it, so there's no need to do any additional
work. If you haven’t performed it, perform
migration, flips the flag or whatever you
have, and put it back. For example, if you
decide to migrate from a zero-based value
to a one-based value, you should introduce
a Boolean flag of whether it performs migration
or not, or otherwise you can increments it
probably twice. It's a rare event but you
do not want to take chances. Another example
is doing reports. So reporting by customer,
you generate report lines and you put report
lines back into database. Again, as I said,
this is not good because you might process
the same customer twice. There is a way out
of this. In your final UI, you can check if
you've got the same report line for twice--double
report line for a customer and you can decide
that, "Hey, I'm going to drop one," but it's
really, really easy to create another idempotent
version. You have to specify a unique name
for report lines. Just, for example, build
it from report idea and customer idea, and
Datastore will make sure that you do not have
double report lines with the same operation.
And what will actually happen here if you're
going to process your customer twice is that
you will try to put it once again, it fails
and the next time there's a first statement
of this report generation function. You should
probably check that you already have a report
line into the database and if you have it,
no need to generate another one. And the last
one, which we had previously, which is obviously
not idempotent function which yields counter
increments. If you process the user twice,
you'll increment it and count it twice. And
frankly speaking, there is no easy way to
achieve idempotence in this case. But one
might argue that you did not need idempotence
in this case. And that’s why in most of
the most legal run your reports over a live
data. Data which is being constantly changes
and by the whole nature reports of these kinds
like distributions of users are approximation.
So if error rate is not really high, you might
have one or two users of like, you will figure
out that there are not 15,000 users of aged
30, but 15,000 plus one user is sorted, so
nobody cares. And these kinds of reports are
really problematic. But we do not know right
now what's the really good idempotent rate
to generates those. So in summary, we've got
the mapper library which is available today.
You can already download it. Play with it.
It's reliable, fast and efficient. It can
iterate over Datastore, or as I have shown
you, it can iterate over blob files. We have
two ways to iterate over blob files already.
The first one is to iterate over zip file
and the other one is to iterate over lines
in a text file so you can easily build whatever
input to your data. We've got Python now and
Java really, really soon. All the code is
fully open-source. And before we go with the
questions, let’s check how our MapReduce
is going on. So, I'm going to refresh the
page and this is the tab job which we have
run and it took two minutes, 49 seconds to
create over one kilobyte of text data which
is probably quite good. I would say that this
is comparable performance with the workstation.
There's are local data and all the data is
in cloud obviously. And if you care, there
is a list of all the crap in the file. So
now we are going back to questions. So if
you haven’t seen, this is the URL which
is bit.ly/ds6t9F. Any live questions while
it loads?
>> This is about idempotency.
>> AIZATSKY: Yes.
>> Typically, when you have idempotency, you
know that all of this data needs to be committed,
right?
>> AIZATSKY: Yes.
>> But let's say there is a business transaction
where there is a counter transaction involved,
like, for example, you book a hotel and then
a car, and then a flight, and then when flight
gets cancelled.
>> AIZATSKY: Yes.
>> And then you go and redo all of them. If
you have already committed and if you're trying
to do an idempotent action in that case, you
know, you need a counter transaction where
idempotent will not, idempotency will not
work.
>> AIZATSKY: Yes, so, basically, what you
need to do is to keep track of which transactions
you have applied recently for example. Just
keep tombstones and just--to make sure that
you haven’t done that.
>> Is...
>> AIZATSKY: What?
>> Is there a project which has something
like change something or a snapshot of a particular
transaction that you are planning to build?
>> AIZATSKY: You see this idempotency is not
connected only to change it, life changing
data. Yes, you could somehow like freeze your
dataset, redirect a live traffic to somewhere
or to like my maintenance page and try to
do MapReduce. But again, the mapper staff
is running on a distributed system which has
failures and it might execute itself twice
on the same entity. So it's just, it's the
way our Google MapReduce work. It’s the
way our MapReduce works. It’s the way Hadoop
works. It's just the way the distributed system
work. Sometimes, you might do this--you have
to be expected to the same work twice. You
could produce tombstones, keeping track of
what has been done or what not.
>> This is pretty sweet, man. Nice job. I
was just wondering it seems like it would
be pretty useful to do some bulk loading of
like big data files. MapReduce is not really
the intention, like would that not be a good
use case for it? So, instead of bulk loading
on the client just like upload a blog...
>> AIZATSKY: Yeah.
>> ...and then process that, create entities.
Would that be like more like efficient?
>> AIZATSKY: Yes, so the question is should
you use mapper staff or Bulkloader and bulk
downloading data. Yes, you probably should
and we do plan to rewrite our Bulkloader and
bulk downloader to users. It just so happens
that these things were developing in parallel
and we do not want to introduce dependencies.
But now, they are ready, we can just rewrite
it. And, in the future, you will be able to
do much more from mapper not just read something,
you would be able to write somewhere and generate
blobs and all those kind of stuff. "So is
it possible to use threads in the map computations?"
It is not possible to use threads in App Engine
right now at all, which means that it is not
possible to use threads in map computation.
"Do you have an example of using App Engine,
MapReduce and combination as Prediction API?"
No, I do not. Frankly, I did not see Prediction
API working at all yet. So but it is, it should
be really, really easy to build such scene,
so like the reader for bitreader of our zip
files was built by one of our developer relations
guy, you know, like 30 minutes. So I would
doubt it's going to be probably easy to adapt
that kind of API. "Please could you compare
the pros and cons of [INDISTINCT] for MapReduce,
Batch Processing versus using the new Google
Storage and the BigQuery APIs." The BigQuery
API is specifically tailored for analyzing
huge datasets while with mapper you can do
much more than that. First of all, you can
work on a mutable data because BigQuery requires
your data to be frozen. You upload it to the
BigStore and you live there forever without
any changes. You can analyze that, it has
some utility value but it's not going to work
over your live changes into Datastore. And
the other thing which is really important,
you can actually change Datastore from the
map library, which is what is being used a
lot like Brett was migrating lots of data,
lots of Hadoop and issuing high [INDISTINCT]
library. "Can you discuss an example of Batch
Processing with Google Storage." Yes, it is
possible to build a reader which will read
data because Google Storage has a block reading,
you can specify offset and read from that
offset. It's very similar to our blobstore
API, so it is possible and it will probably
build its own reader which will iterate over
dating Google Storage. We do not care where
the data comes from. As soon as you can fetch
data, as soon as you can efficiently split
it, you can you can integrate over like S
three dataset if you need to. "And how can
App Engine overcome bandwidth's limitation
if Batch Processing is to be done in the cloud?"
Upload your data to the cloud and you won't
have bandwidth problems. So anymore questions
from the audience?
>> So I have an application which I’d like
to send say, for example, 5,000 emails pretty
rapidly and I normally would have just used
the Task Queue, but it seems like it maybe
really easy to do using the mapper, right,
as I understand it.
>> AIZATSKY: Yes, you can you can do whatever
you want from map record. You can write any
kind of code inside mapper. Any legal App
Engine code is legal to use inside the map
handler functions. If you want to send exemplifi
messages, fine. Just send those. We just build
those yielding operations because we have
provided it some special properties like we
batch them together.
>> So you took away a lot of the complexity
of writing my own Task Queues?
>> AIZATSKY: Yes, that’s kind of the idea,
kind of interesting.
>> Super.
>> AIZATSKY: So you can send emails, notifications,
whatever. And great limit, it is especially
important for sending emails because you cannot
send more than certain amounts of emails per
fixed amount of time. You're not a spammer.
Yes, probably.
>> Can I ask?
>> AIZATSKY: Yes.
>> The bulk downloader...
>> ...is it true that by default--I mean,
I have to write a class to download--I would
think that if I want to download, shouldn’t
it just download everything in that entity?
You know, look, why do I have to write a class
to do, in the exporter class? And the future
one will it do everything by default?
>> AIZATSKY: Honestly, I cannot comment about
Bulk Downloader because I'm not purely on
top of the recent development.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> AIZATSKY: So you should probably come to
our office hours and there might be people
who know about that.
>> And you don’t know about the future either,
because you said that it's going to be part
of mapper.
>> AIZATSKY: Yes, like Brett...
>> SLATKIN: I'm sorry. So, [INAUDIBLE] going
to talk [INDISTINCT] going to talk [INDISTINCT]
syntax for import and export, like you download
everything. And then, the idea for these things
to report together in the future so you could
use mapper so you could both import and export,
to make it much more efficient. So, that's--okay.
>> How does it compare to Adobe?
>> AIZATSKY: We're trying to give open sourced
friendly APIs so that you are familiar with
Adobe then you can run your code in App Engine
with little or maybe even no modifications.
So, in the future one, we’ll have a full
MapReduce stack, this produced part which
we'd like to give you sooner than later. You'll
be able to run almost Adobe code on this stuff,
but there are no connections with Adobe implementations
per se.
>> Is it going to be faster?
>> AIZATSKY: Well, Adobe does not work on
a Google infrastructure.
>> Yes, but...
>> AIZATSKY: So, we cannot, we cannot use
it.
>> But doing the same kind of analysis on
your MapReduce and on Adobe, which one would
be faster?
>> AIZATSKY: Sorry, I did not get the...
>> If you ran the same--let's say you want
to analyze, you run your own crap search...
>> AIZATSKY: Yes.
>> …on Google and then you run the same
on Adobe.
>> AIZATSKY: Yeah, so, if your engineer would
careful enough then the odds are high that
you would be able to run the same result modifications
in the header cluster or in the App Engine
cluster.
>> But do you know which one will be faster
to be able to...
>> AIZATSKY: No idea.
>> [INDISTINCT].
>> AIZATSKY: Right now, though we are quite
pleased with its performance, the performance
was not our goal right now. So our goal was
to give you as flexible as easy to as possible.
And, if we figure out that there are customers
who care about certain terabytes, we'll see
what we’re going to do next.
>> Thanks.
>> Hi. You know, so once you have the APIs
in place, map and reduce and they're kind
of proven, would you consider switching out
the implementation to allow for a more parallel
execution? Instead of using the chaining technique
internally but, you know, if that’s abstracted
away...
>> AIZATSKY: Yes, we do consider that direction.
But right now, we realized that probably most
of our customers are small to medium apps.
By medium I mean medium datasets by Google
standards. So as soon as there is a customer
who has hundreds of terabytes of data, we
might give him another solution.
>> So, if I ask the right people perhaps there's
a preview, something coming up.
>> AIZATSKY: Well, we have nothing to announce
at this point.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you.
>> AIZATSKY: So, thank you all for coming.
I hope you'll try it and you'll find it useful
for your apps.